everybody welcome to live coding with
Jessie I'm Jessie and today we're going
to keep working on these react
components so I've just been like
grinding through stuff yesterday and
today I was I have a side project now
that I'm working on it's like a
blockchain wallet so I was up last night
late working on that too which we're
doing that and react native so that's
kind of cool
but I'm just trying to like balance
being able to work and trying to stay in
that flow State and like going too far
and getting burnt out so right now
definitely not burn out just a little
bit tired probably after I do the stream
I might get something eaten do a workout
and then I should be good to go
and I'll go work on my side price hex
but maybe I'll let you know a little bit
more about that project later on and
maybe I'll do some something on my own
channel but for now we're gonna work
with C I just noticed something yeah
just there is an issue with the faculty
list item component so that's what we'll
start with I'll show you what the issue
is first in the UI and then we'll go to
the component and we'll fix that and we
may actually create an entirely new
component a new page today as well but
let's fix this first so I think if I
don't fix it now I'll probably forget
about it all right let me get we get my
screen ready
I'll get my screen ready and then also
I'm going to set my Pomodoro timer
okay I got everything the screen ready
for you all so let me switch it over
okay and I can't remember it wasn't this
green which one was it
let me check here okay I think it was
psychology and social work
let's see a thing it was this page No
maybe so I've been working on all these
faculty list pages and making sure that
in the router we have a min properly and
like halfway through the list of the
faculty list pages it the the URL
switched up so sometimes it's just like
the program slash faculty so it would be
like English slash faculty but sometimes
it changes so it's it would be
Department slash English chefs faculty
so for some programs it uses that and
for some programs it uses the other one
and there's no like it's not like
there's two URLs and they both could
have say in place it has to be one or
the other
so I had to finish out the routing
function to be able to handle things
with three parameters which we never
really finished that because we hadn't
we didn't need it yet so I had to do
that make some adjustments in the
routing function so check out the last
couple commits if you're interested in
that but when I was doing that I noticed
this so her last name is O'Brien right
with a little what is it
' yeah I can't even think a little
apostrophe right so and I know we fix
this issue before does anybody watching
know how to fix this and remember how we
did it before I feel like I'm in class
but I just I just want to see if anybody
else how you all would fix this
I'll give you all a second and I'll
answer a question while I'm while I'm
waiting cool deep asks can you give a
rough idea for how you built your timer
I want to make it - actually I did not
build that timer so the timer that I'm
using it was built by Harsha he was in
this channel quite a bit so if he if
he's able to make it today then we can
we can ask him when he comes into the
channel I think his breaks over and he's
back to school though so I'm not I don't
think I'll be able to make it very often
now but I mean this is early enough in
the day that he he might not be sleeping
yet so cool deep ass how can I contact
him mmm I think what the best way would
be I guess he's on Twitter yeah send me
a direct message on Twitter my links in
the profile or in the description of the
video the link to my Twitter profile is
in the description of this video send me
a DM and then I'll I'll connect you with
her [ __ ] I don't want to like put out
harsh it's Twitter info on the stream in
case he doesn't want me to okay so the
way we're gonna fix this is we're going
to use dangerously set inner HTML right
it's okay to do that because we have
control of the content don't you
definitely do not want to do that if
you're allowing users to enter in their
own content and then have it display
because bad things could happen let's
see John also says maybe you could find
them with the regular expression raptly
but it's bad huh sorry yeah I should say
it's not like there's one way to deal
with this but we're just gonna do the
way that we've usually dealt with this
and we have the the
shouldn't do it this way like I said
because we have control of our data this
is not an option in in all cases though
all right
so oh that's way too small let me make
that bigger okay let me know if that's
big enough if I need to go bigger and I
don't need that sidebar to be that big
and there's not even anything on this
page oh all right cool
so here's our faculty list and so we're
not actually going well just to show you
on our faculty list page we're taking in
that data that we're getting from
WordPress one of the pieces of data that
we're getting is the title and that's
the that's the little bit that has that
that name with the apostrophe in it so
we're grabbing that data and we're
passing it as a prop called profile name
to our faculty list item component so
now let's go into the faculty list item
component and let's find where we're
using that profile name prop all right
so we've done that our D structuring up
here so we can just say profile name we
don't have to use this props all the
time which is convenient and let's find
profile name there it is okay so you can
see we're just putting profile name in
here we're not setting dangerously
setting the innerhtml so we're gonna do
that to do that I'm gonna copy and paste
where we're doing it here with with our
title and it's kind of odd that I didn't
think to do this before since we were
already doing it and looks like oh just
one other place but what we can do here
then is put in
a profile name I don't think we'll need
to add the zero I'm not sure why we have
that in title I don't remember what
happened there that that made us have to
do that and then we can get rid of this
closing tag and just add our slash in
here let's save it and see if it works
see what happens hey there we go so now
it's switched up and we can see this is
displayed properly along you know
everything else was already looking good
but now that's displayed properly so we
won't have to worry about something like
that happening again so that's awesome
that's one quick win right off the bat
so I'm gonna commit that if you if you
weren't with me yesterday I had I had
vowed yesterday that I was gonna try to
stick to my own advice of committing
often so I'm gonna try to keep it up
let's do get status yep that's what
changed and so we can do a get ad let's
run our yarn cm and we'll fix and let's
see faculty news with
that is very properly and I don't think
I ever made an issue about that because
I just saw it not too long ago so that
should be good
we'll make sure it passes the test and
then we can push it and lately I've been
going through a lot of the open issues
and just trying to close some of them
because we were starting to get a lot of
issues that we're open so the next one I
noticed that shouldn't be too difficult
to do is creating a template page for
jobs so this is issue 107 if you want to
check out the get repo for this the
links in the description
okay so let me just explain what I want
to do here and if you want to follow
along you can read it all as well in the
issue but so right now on the site we
have job listings and they're split up
into two categories faculty and staff so
we're basically we're the routes for
these pages are gonna be / HR / faculty
openings and / HR / staff openings so
both routes are gonna go to the same
component to be rendered but then within
that component we are going to grab the
data and filter it so we probably won't
filter it we'll probably do is use we're
gonna create a new graph keel query and
we're only gonna grab the posts the job
listing post for that particular
category cool the men will list them all
in a similar way that we we just saw
with those faculty profiles and then
we'll need to make I'm gonna
double-check on the current site but I
believe each one of them will have to
have its own page as well so will be
just like the faculty profiles will
you'll be able to click to learn more
and then it will open up its own page
[Music]
I'll have to see what the euro should be
for those as well but the first thing we
need to do is create the new component
and create I can't talk today grades a
new component and create the graph Keo
query that's it okay yep and it looks
like everything passed wonderful so big
it push that is now available on github
all right so let's check out our pages
folder and let's see make sure I didn't
already make something for this nope all
right and since we already have the
faculty list page up and it's gonna be
similar to our jobs page let's just copy
and paste our faculty list page and then
we'll modify it and turn it into our
jobs page we're going to select
everything copy it and let's make a new
a new file called jobs God now it'll be
let's make a job list I could make it
plural jobs and then also have a
template for a job like just job but I
think it's way more clear if you add the
list at the end it's a lot easier to
just mistake the two when there's only
one character difference so we're gonna
say job list is and then depending on
how much time we have maybe we'll make
the single job page as well okay so we
need to change the name here so faculty
list I was hoping I could just select
all these but I can't right now so let's
just call this jobless just a jobless
component and job list whoops okay so we
changed the name and this is now a job
list
we do have to remember to make a route
for this in the router or we'll never be
able to get to it
okay we're gonna name we're gonna rename
our query as well so actually you may be
able to grab all the query stuff at once
your job list query and we need to grab
this from job list so on our other panel
here let's work on our query and we can
again we'll be able to copy that query
that we're already using and just adjust
it so in our queries
we'll take that faculty list query we're
gonna copy that and make a new file
we're gonna call this job list touch is
just paste it in there and job list
what's that
can't remember if that's capitalized or
not yep it is faculty list so we'll
capitalize that for job list and then
let's change it here as well job list
and instead of faculty departments I
believe we can just say charm
I may have to double check to make sure
what I named that particular post type
yeah let's see and then it's not gonna
be faculty yeah let me let me go back to
say I'm not looking at departments we're
looking at yeah I need to check let's go
to our WordPress installation and check
will we name these because I created
this post site a long time ago I believe
I created the right taxonomy as well if
I didn't then I need to make it cuz
that's gonna be important okay jobs oh
it I don't think I have any taxonomy set
up so we may be doing some PHP for a
minute
no there's nothing okay all right let's
do that quickly hopefully play I have
this repo download it already on my
other screen I'm gonna get this opened
up
okay I think I do have it great cool
okay all right so I'm gonna open this up
and pull it over so we can check this
out all right so here's our our plug in
our Franciscan custom post type stuff
PHP file here so here's a wordpress
plug-in and we have jobs we may as well
look up what we named jobs so it looks
like it's just its job okay so that's
that's pretty simple to remember but now
we need to go down here to our taxonomy
z' and let's check this out
okay yeah so we definitely need to add
that taxonomy so let's grab let's grab
the staff departments code we're gonna
copy and paste that to create a new sort
of staff department will call this we're
gonna create a new taxonomy job job
category you know what now I remember
why I didn't make this before I was
gonna use the advanced custom fields
plug-in to just make a like a radio
filled with it's a radio button that you
can either pick staff or faculty instead
of an entirely new taxonomy but at this
point that's going to take longer so I'm
just gonna do it like this add Emma
I have us a how do people on you do you
want to watch me code okay you gotta be
quiet though cuz we're gonna try to do
something now alright okay alright so
let's take all these
instances where it's a staff Department
and let's change it to job category and
we'll do the same thing here
you know what
yeah I guess it's okay you know I will
need to start using that advanced custom
fields plug-in at some point so we might
maybe we'll do that on a stream let me
know if you're interested in how do we
set that up and use it I do need to
double check and make sure that it will
work with graph QL
category
all right so we're going to job
categories and then down here we'll do
the same thing we'll camelcase them for
that
WP graph QL plug-in things need to be
camel case
all right oh they're talking to you this
is my daughter her name's Gemma and they
say you're cute Gemma she's hood and
microphones not have dozens checking it
out okay all right actually we're gonna
do I'm gonna say this and whoops this
needs to be okay I had a drink right
there but luckily it was in a like a
travel mug instead of just a glass it
would have been all over the place okay
so my timer is up so I'm gonna stop here
before we check out to see if it'll work
so it'll be suspenseful while I answer
questions for five minutes so we're
going to do short break I'm gonna scroll
all the way up to the top and try to
answer as many questions as I can in in
five minutes and then we'll go back to
this okay the quiet will let me let me
see the question okay I see a lot of you
just saying saying hi so hey everyone
desh desh mu says sorry if I
mispronounced that let me know how I
should pronounce it but anyway they say
tell us more about that blockchain
wallet side project okay yeah I'll
briefly talk about that it's so there is
a website called git coin
so it's GI t COI n I can't remember if
it's maybe it's dot IO I'm not sure but
anyway the idea behind it is that you
take
open github issues for projects and then
you set a bounty on them and it's a
certain amount of cryptocurrency so if
you complete if you've solved that issue
then you get that that bounty right in
cryptocurrency so I get emails
occasionally from that website that'll
just update me on some things I might be
interested in working on and I saw one
and it was using react and it had a
decent bounty on it so I thought hey
I'll try this out but by the time I
submitted a request to work on it
someone else had already requested it so
they they got it first but then I got to
talking to the person that maintains
that repo and they were saying that
they're also working on you know
different projects that's porting this
web app to a react native app and they
asked if I had experience with react
native and I said yeah and I sent him
some of my repos and so now I'm working
on that so at this point I'm just kind
of working on UI stuff so I have some
sketch files about how it's supposed to
look and I'm trying to get that all
sorted you know as soon as I can
I think it's a really really useful web
app and I really want to use the the app
itself last attack in my info and saw it
and it's it's really cool it gives you
all your basically you give it your meta
mask wallet address and it it lists out
all your coins and then the value of
your coins and you know whatever
currency you select Priyanka says can
you please tell me how to get a job if
someone is new to coding if you're new
to coding the best thing to do is like
keep learning keep working on projects
and you may I mean it depends a lot on
where your
at and and what your skill level is but
if you find if there's like an agency or
something where you work or you know a
company that's throwing websites or
whatever you want to work on you could
ask them submit your resumes even if
you're not hiring and just okay I'll
I'll work is a contract worker hourly
basis or something that could open up
the door for you to work on projects
that you wouldn't normally be able to
get on your own and clients that you
would never be able to have access to on
your own since you're just trying to
build up your reputation so that's one
way to do it another way is just to
reach out to clients on your own you
know small businesses in your area that
might need you know work done you can
try websites that lists work if you want
i-i've never had great luck with those
there's a lot of competition you usually
don't get paid that much but if you
don't have any other way to build your
portfolio that's a way to do it I've
even heard of people picking a business
that has let's say like a terrible
website and redoing their website for
free and then going to the business and
showing them what they've done and
saying that would you be interested in
you know in having this website so you
know those are just a few ways I'm sure
there's a lot more that I'm forgetting
but you know basically your focus at
this point should be just building up
your portfolio preferably with with
projects for real clients but in the
meantime if you don't have paying work
try your best to keep learning keep
doing projects that at least you can put
in your github profile and in your
portfolio
- Mook says how does react.js work for
search engine optimization we are using
server-side rendering for this and you
need to do that if you want to use react
and you want to use data that you're
pulling in from an API you need to
render it on the server-side for search
engines to see it you can do that
a variety of ways the easiest way that I
found is just to use next J s because it
comes automatically with server-side
rendering so that's what we are using
right now okay and my timer is up so I'm
gonna have to come back and finish
answering the questions after the next
Pomodoro session so let's see if we can
get this component up and running hey
Gemma I can't see my screen
yeah I'm gonna look at that one now
we're gonna go back and do some more
code okay let's see
okay here's what else I'd like to do I
think it might not be a bad idea to add
some more categories to the jobs this
could it can help users sort better
right so let's add in addition to adding
this to staff the staff members we're
gonna add it to jobs both job and staff
Department and there should be a faculty
should be a faculty department as well
there we go so faculty department you
can see it's already used on a variety
of post types and we're gonna add in job
to this as well
alright so now I'm just gonna copy and
paste this into WordPress there are
better ways to get your code into
WordPress but this would be the fastest
way right now since I don't have other
way set up and GEMA try not to wiggle
the chair I'm I'm gonna get motion sick
and so does everybody watching okay so
we're gonna go down here to plugins into
our editor and let's we're gonna go that
for instance in Franciscan custom post
type plug-in and now we can just copy
and paste that oops I accidentally hit
save like it was in my editor it's not
we're gonna update that and we should be
able to see the changes immediately if
we did it right maybe I didn't do it
right let me give it a refresh and now
let's see yep here we go so now we have
faculty department staff department oh
and the category is called job we don't
really want that I messed that up let's
change that really quick because that's
going to be confusing so job yeah we
need to say job category up here job
[Music]
Caterpie
okay all right save that copy it and we
still have this up on the screen which
is good we'll update that and that
should work now we'll give it a refresh
and there we go now it says job category
so that's wonderful so now if we go into
jobs we should have there we go we have
all these options and if we were to go
into this this job clinical nursing
instructor we can see that we can select
these things here and we can add a new
job category so we could say faculty as
one category and staff as the other
so now faculty and staff are there all
right now clinical nursing instructor
would be a faculty position so we're
gonna uncheck staff and then we can say
it within our faculty Department we can
check nursing department update that and
now if we go back to check all our jobs
so now we can see our department and our
category
oh no did I mess up category I
misspelled category No
alright I think I spelled it right in
the slug so that's good because it won't
mess up too much yeah I spelled it right
in the slug so that that's really what
matters more like for the database are
you coding in your notebook Jemma's over
here writing the code that we're writing
she's writing it in a notebook she's
coding along with us okay third time's a
charm here right let's paste this in and
now we'll have the the right spelling
thanks for uh for letting me know about
that
okay while Eugene you've warned but
thanks don't it bro
oh you know like question yeah there we
go alright so that works now and now we
can commit this change and push it up to
get up
so let's see get add and we're gonna say
new feature let me say add John I mean
why Exxon amazed to job site
all right great and so now this this
plugin is tracked on on github so you
can check that out if you if you want to
and now now we'll be able to do this
so alright so let me think how we're
gonna do this I guess the big yeah the
first thing that we want to filter by I
guess is actually let's let's think
about this so right now let's go to the
save right now I'm trying to think of a
if we could create a better user
experience than what we have right now
all right so let's go through the steps
that a user would take if they wanted to
find a job listing to work at Franciscan
University we're gonna do this now
anyway you know we may as well give this
some thought we don't have to copy the
actual user experience you know as it
currently is okay
so we've come to the site and probably
about about an employment and Human
Resources ok so now that I'm here I
either click see open faculty positions
or see open staff positions let's open
both of them because I believe these
pages are pretty much the same
let's see yeah so faculty openings these
are all the same lengths okay this is
pretty much it
yes I mean this is pretty much the same
the only difference that I could see
there's a different image in the
background so no big deal because we're
not bringing images over right now
anyway so here's my my idea what if in
the router we made it so that both of
those routes would go to the same page
and from there then you could have
filters like we did with the search page
like we've done with with other projects
and one of the filters would be do you
want faculty openings or staff openings
I really think that's better because I
mean to be honest with you it's entirely
possible that someone might just want to
work here and they may be looking for
any opening faculty or staff perhaps
they they do have a higher degree and
they're qualified to do a variety of
things they come in here you know if
they've clicked on one let's say they
didn't do like we did and open up new
windows for both which probably would be
the best way to go about this how it's
currently set up but let's say they
didn't and then they'd have to go to a
different page to look at the different
openings right there's actually nothing
like no way to sort these at all so you
can see like there's not that many jobs
right now but it still would be nice to
sort them occasionally we do have a lot
of openings so you know if we had what
is that like 10 opening somewhere on
there nah just guessing 10 openings plus
another couple openings and faculty
like that's that's enough openings that
you know maybe you might want to sort it
great in my mind I'm just thinking like
when I've gone before two sites to try
to find a job it is it's a little bit
annoying to have to scroll through a lot
of things that I'm I'm not even
interested in or qualify for to try to
find you know the one thing especially
if I've heard from someone like hey
they're hiring you know somebody here
and I go to check it out and I got to
scroll through all this stuff it's a lot
nicer if I could just search or click a
category and go right to it
so if we're trying to attract candidates
I'd rather get as many applications as
possible here and the best way to do
that is to make it easier so anyway let
me know what you think am i overthinking
this or not either way I don't know
we've already category categories we've
made a taxonomy in WordPress so you know
we may as well utilize them at the very
least there'll be one less link that we
have to include in the menu so we'll
just say you know employment
opportunities or something like that as
the length and I think that would that
would be better hey Jemma yeah don't
mess with the cord you unplug all this
stuff yeah all right so let's do that
then so what we'll do here then is we're
gonna grab this is gonna be simplified
now because we're not gonna do any
filtering within our query we're gonna
leave that all up to the component so at
we're just gonna grab everything
so let's go let's clean this up a bit
and let's get rid of this part we won't
need this anymore and let's see we do
need to slug we need the name
I don't know fool we have now you know
what they have these images but I don't
I don't think these it's just the same
image over and over occasionally we
throw in a different one so I'm not I
don't think images are necessary right
now let's see what the big page looks
like I wonder where they're pulling this
from if this is a separate thing okay
just
okay for now I'm not gonna show any of
this stuff we'll just leave it with the
title and then we'll see what we have
we'll see if we want to add some more in
so basically we just need the name in
the slug and we don't want faculty
departments and we don't need we're
right cuz we just need jobs and we don't
need this part
actually that's a let's test out our
let's test out our query first so we're
gonna go in here and use our little tool
here so our graph graph eql I don't know
how you supposed to pronounce that but
there's an eye in there so I'm gonna say
graph eql and let's see if this query
works
oh I go getting save again nope
all right what do we do wrong name
okay so evidently name is not an option
okay so we can get the jobs which is
definitely cool so we get the jobs and
we can't use a name let's see what we
can use yep we can use title great all
right cool it's not all the jobs that we
have so it's all we have more or is that
whoa
yeah we definitely have a law of war
I wonder if we have some type of like
limit is 10 the default
I'm gonna have to check the
documentation for that WP graph QL
plug-in and see what what the defaults
are for the number of posts it returns
yeah
okay but for now at least we can get
some data back so we don't yeah we
actually don't need all this right now
we could take this down a little bit
more
okay
slug let's
we list item do we have
wonder if we can use the faculty list
item
you know we're not doing any checks
right now to make sure any of this
content is coming in
I'm thinking about making this a little
bit more reusable
you know what we do have some really
specific things going on
all right I hate making another
component that's like so specific but
actually you know what let's let's wait
let's test it first so what we can do
then is instead of this say what do we
have
okay this data so let's say job let's
call this job data
chubs data and then in here we'll switch
this up the job and we're actually gonna
get rid of most of this and we don't we
don't eat it to be like that see cuz our
data's gonna come back like this so to
be data jobs edges and that's what we'll
need so it would just be
data jobs edges okay so that's our jobs
data that's what we're gonna map over so
each one is gonna be a job we have our
slug that'll work and then here we're
gonna do our let's see job node title
we're just gonna put this inside of an
h1 let's do an h2 okay so that'll be big
so let's add job node title and up here
we're not using this so let's get rid of
this let's save both of these see if
this works
hopefully I didn't mess this up too much
that it's broken now but we can go to
let's let's see if the routes there I
doubt the route is there about HR
faculty opening no to that routes not
there let's add the route in our server
I wonder if we have an HR spot already
anyway
think that was it HR okay so we have our
HR page let's change this up so this is
the default it just defaults to page but
then we also want when we get faculty
openings
we want it to render from our new jobs
list so we called it now we call it job
list okay so we wanted to render to that
and then with our type post our type
should be okay because we're not
actually using the type at all and then
for our ID well we need an ID I don't
think we'll need an ID not yet at least
okay so let's save that see at least if
we can get it to to render
mm-hm well there we go it was the
servers rooster
all right so that's not working what do
we do I see what our error is which
y'all can't see that here yeah
Oh graph QL syntax error okay all right
so I mess that up let's see
let me see what this query is
trying to find a similar query to what
we need
I don't write queries often enough to be
good at them it seems like I'm always
alright unexpected name of jobs that's
what it did work for us here right yeah
we can see what we get
oh it worked great just unique he just
said extra set of braces needed yep that
was it nice all right cool so what we
have when we go here to faculty openings
is a list of openings awesome
really cool
awesome so that works so I believe my
timer went off again there's least as
close to it yeah a timer went off again
so basically from here what I will do is
I'll put a little title up here so you
know what page were on and then I'll add
in some I don't know where I'll put them
maybe on this side basically I'll add in
something some options so that users can
filter I'll figure out how to have more
than 10 at once and then I'll add in
routes so we're gonna do it have a route
for staff opening that'll go to the same
place and then we'll just have a route
for job openings and that's what we'll
link to but just in case somebody at
bookmark disk it'll still take them to
the right place they just may need to
click the button and then eventually you
know there's people get used to the new
link you know we don't really get visits
to the old links anymore okay all right
cool so I'll probably keep working on
this a little bit so I can get it to a
point where maybe I can just make it
commit I mean really at this point it
does work so I got I mean I could commit
this
it's not like it's I'm committing it in
a broken state but I want to get back to
your questions now and I'm gonna try to
answer all your questions and then we're
gonna wrap things up
Oh Nicky said it still has no idea what
a taxonomy is let me alright so a
taxonomy is just a category or a tag in
in WordPress so it's it's just a way to
organize posts all right
Dickie Allen says I'm currently going
through the free code camp curriculum
and applied CSS still and I have gotten
pretty far in a Python udemy course I'm
starting to understand object-oriented
programming and Python is there a good
place to really find out what you should
focus on like what skills give results
in particular fields I'm not sure what I
really want to do I like JavaScript uh I
said like is there a site that covers
specific languages and what you get out
of them
interesting I'm not I'm not sure that
there's a site that does that just in
general if you want to be in web
development Java scripts definitely the
way to go
you're not stuck with web development
you can develop apps with react native
and JavaScript there are ways to do
machine learning with JavaScript there
are even ways to do VR and AR stuff with
JavaScript but in terms of like machine
learning Python seems to be the most
popular if you wanted to do native apps
I don't know how much Java is still used
but that's would you use to use and then
with iOS Ben dotnet framework so
yeah so I don't know a site that lists
all of that if anybody knows of anything
like that it would actually pretty
useful so please let us know I hope a ho
player says may you explain the register
taxonomy object the bullying's and other
values etc where are those who I used to
find all right let's check it out so
register taxonomy so a lot of this is
just extending what's already in
WordPress core so you know we're not
really like you know building up our own
programming stuff here we are just
telling WordPress you know hey WordPress
you already have this function called
register taxonomy like here's here's all
the arguments that that function takes
to create a new taxonomy so you could
see like I don't know if it's different
terminology for Python but like for
JavaScript land like all right this is
your function and all your arguments are
within these parentheses so first off
you know we're saying the name job
categories and then we have an array the
second parameter here is okay what is
this going to apply to and so we give it
a ray of the slugs for each post type
that we wanted to apply to and then the
third parameter is an array of all these
attributes that we would like it to have
so you know all these attributes are our
options they're even more than this but
these are all options that we can set
for our particular taxonomy that we
wanted to have so you know for instance
we want it to be available in the REST
API we want it to be available through
graph QL so
hopefully that explains a bit I don't
know enough about WordPress core to like
really go through more of it this top
part here this is the labels array so
like that gets inserted here so this one
is just I mean you can see how it would
be a match to put it right in here so
obviously like we make this variable for
that so the labels these all have to do
with how you will display this in the UI
the WordPress admin UI so these are just
the names that we give to you know the
this different spots so that's why I
like you know even though I have spelled
category correctly down here and
actually said job category when we
looked in the UI
it only spelled job and then when I
tried to fix it it spelled job category
but category was spelled wrong because
you know this is just the display stuff
all right let me know if if I didn't
answer your question properly or if I if
I misunderstood it Dickey also asks is
there a good reference for what to
charge clients if the figure would be
good to charge less or to do stuff free
at first but you don't want to kill the
job market yeah yeah so yeah in general
like you you want to get experience
right but you don't don't want to sell
yourself short so yeah there when you
first start out there probably gonna be
times when you'll do work for less than
you really want to do it but what you're
doing is you know basically you can
consider yourself in a paid internship
at that point because you're still
learning and anything you get from a
client is gonna be better than just
doing side projects on your own and not
getting paid anything so you find a
client that you you know maybe something
that you think will be good for your
port
and you know try to get what you can but
at that point it's it's not necessarily
about the money because you're trying to
build yourself up to where you could
actually make the money so if you need
money you know right away you know then
you may need to do some other jobs that
are non-coding related to get the money
I mean not I did when I was starting out
but you want to transition into
hopefully like building so each new
client you get you'll be able to charge
a little bit more hopefully getting into
bigger projects you know more steady
work but you you got to build somewhere
so you got to start up building your
portfolio so that you can justify your
price to the client so that you can
prove to the client that you're gonna
bring value to them based on your past
projects so that you can point to this
and say you know I did this website for
this small business it was similar to
yours their profits increased by this
much you know after the website launched
something like that right if you can
ship prove that then it'll be worth so
much so even if you didn't get paid that
much to do it the first time after that
you can quantify your value the value of
your work to clients and then what
you're gonna get paid is not gonna be
based on you know what somebody thinks
you're worth it's gonna be based on the
value that your work will bring to them
as in you know if you do this project
for them they will make an extra I don't
know five thousand dollars a month right
then your work is worth close to five
thousand dollars a month right because
they're gonna come out on top from that
investment is it hopefully that makes
sense I mean there's a lot of different
ways to approach pricing that's just
kind of one of the ways but like I said
when you're just starting out the idea
should be figure out what you like to do
and build up a good
folio and and then it's gonna be a heck
of a lot easier to get those higher
paying clients and make sure you're
really professionally make a good name
for yourself especially locally if word
gets out that you're not reliable you'll
have a much harder time getting work you
know it's if you're trying to get remote
work from different places you know
maybe it won't get out but you know with
the internet like you don't want to ruin
your reputation right away just because
you think oh well this this guy's not
you know this clients not paying me that
much anyway
no he's you know be professional no
matter what you're making did you never
know what kind of referrals you could
get or what kind of damage it could do
if you get bad reviews
Chad says do you have videos for
creating custom themes for WordPress
actually no I am I've never done a
custom WordPress theme video so usually
I don't make WordPress themes I just
used their REST API or graph QL with
WordPress to pull out the data and I
just sometimes I just delete the theme
so I don't use them at all but I mean
some of these things like being able to
make new post types and taxonomies you
know they could definitely help you if
you're building a theme world says you
should be vice-president of dev you know
what they should make that position and
give it to me that would be awesome
alpha says how cool is Visual Studio
code is integrated terminal and debug
console huh oh yeah for sure I love it I
love it so convenient especially when
I'm trying to stream it's all that right
on one screen I don't have to flip
around between screens hey harsh it made
it hard says I'm busy these days tons of
schoolwork that's why I'm an active yeah
I figured I figured you had school I
remember you telling me so yeah don't
worry about it school comes first for
sure
Francis says ass calves or warriors I
don't know I don't I don't really have a
basketball team so like growing up
there's no basketball team close to me
I usually side with like all Pittsburgh
teams because I grew up close to
Pittsburgh but they don't have a
basketball team so there's never a big
thing for me I guess if I had to pick I
would say Cavs because that they're like
as close as I have to a hometown NBA
team
it's Stacey says hello hey hey Stacey
how's it going
world says how do you avoid getting
tired of coding I can only code like 30
minutes a day hmm I don't know I guess I
mean to probably two things like one
I do enjoy coding now there's three
three three reasons why I can code for a
long time one I enjoy coding number two
I have years of experience of coding for
long periods of time so I've built up my
mind to be able to handle that right
because I I think it's like your body
right you couldn't just go out and run
for hours and hours if you haven't run
that much before right it's the same way
with coding like you couldn't just sit
down in code for hours and hours your
brain would be really tired right so and
the third reason is money right I have
to pay the bills so if I'm gonna get
paid to code all day like I'm gonna code
all day because if I don't like my
family is not gonna have anywhere to
live or they're not gonna have anything
to eat my kids won't be able to you know
have any any toys or games or anything
like that so that's also if all else
fails the fact that I have to do it for
my job
will you know keep me coding
okay Nikki was saying that page also
needs to dangerously set HTML does it
and I bring it in it does yeah yeah off
to do that I mean it for for right now I
just wanted to make sure that that query
works but yeah you're right it when I
start styling that for real it's it's
gonna be dangerous
dangerously set enter HTML to avoid this
kind of stuff let's see oh okay is it
alright so I guess at some point you
couldn't hear me sorry about that it's
possible maybe I covered up the mic
hopefully it's alright now
gabru says how can I learn JavaScript
there's a lot of different resources you
can use to learn JavaScript I recommend
checking out free code camp so free code
camp org will steer you in the right
direction
you can also it depends on how you like
to learn if you like to read books to
learn check out the book series called
you don't know J s and if you also
eloquent JavaScript is a good one and
then if you like YouTube videos the free
code camp YouTube channel has some good
tutorial videos as well question is
please could you clarify how to jump
from HTML to sass in Visual Studio code
CSS peek only works with CSS as CSS less
in sublime plugin go to CSS definition
it allows me to jump to sass thanks in
advance I have no idea how to do that
with with sass so I don't use that
feature in Visual Studio code so if
anybody else uses that please let us
know in the chat but yeah unfortunately
I can't help you with that because I
don't use it
i Yamamoto says how's how's the health
insurance in the developer world my
health insurance is pretty good and I
would do work for university so it's a
little different it's not like a tech
company or anything most of the job
descriptions for developer jobs here in
the United States that I've seen do
include health insurance so I'm not sure
about you know what it's like in other
countries but at least in the United
States you know you should probably
expect to get health insurance from a
developer job and it it seems rare that
insurance isn't offered Matt Dutchess
says I think that the you don't know
jeaious has an entire series on github
for free yeah yeah for sure it's it's
for free so both of those books that I
mentioned you can get online for free
whole place is usually in a well made
site how much of it is custom made and
how much depends on frameworks and api's
it just depends it depends and custom
made is not always better
you know there's frameworks are are very
helpful and they are been tested in a
lot of situations so they can definitely
be less buggy than something custom made
I have more kids here so let me switch
it up there we go
there's Rafael and Gemma gonna say hi
so yeah I mean I would I mean it
entirely depends like if you see a well
made site maybe it's custom maybe it's
all frameworks it's just the quality of
the site is not dependent on how much is
custom and how much this frame works and
in my opinion John Hanson says free code
can't put up your owl live coding
changed my life YouTube video on their
channel oh cool cool I thought they
might put that up I didn't know they did
though that's awesome
mmm-hmm mad that's just as well cuties
yeah happy father yeah yeah I love being
a father alright and I've gotten to the
the end of the chat so thank you all so
much for hanging out with me while I do
my work and catching my mistakes which
is super helpful and it's the end of the
week so I don't think I'll be doing any
streaming over the weekend you never
know if I do it maybe just might be
something real low-key in my own channel
which you can find a link to my channel
in the description also I promised I
wouldn't mention this very often I
haven't talked about it all week for a
week at least I did start a patreon page
so you can find the link from my youtube
channel in the description to sunlight
my newer videos and things so if you're
interested in maybe supporting me only
if you have a little extra to spare but
if you do please check out my patreon
channel and I'm not going to spam you
with requests I'll mention it
occasionally but it would really help me
out to be able to do things like get
better equipment for streaming or
potentially dedicate more of my time to
creating content for you all so yeah so
any little bit helps
I really appreciate it and if you have
any any suggestions for things that
you'd like to see you on my patreon like
reward levels and things like that let
me know because I'm definitely new at it
and I'm not sure what you all want I'm
just kind of guessing at this point so
let me know alright cool so I'll see you
all again on Monday and until then have
a wonderful weekend